boris johnson has promised a smooth and
sensible shift from
fossil fuels to renewable power but the
pm has been criticized
for his comments today claiming that
margaret thatcher had given the uk an
early start
in the fight against climate change when
coal mines
across the uk were closed in the 1980s
well let's get more on that with sky's
chief political correspondent john craig
so let me get this straight then john
boris johnson's thesis
is that margaret thatcher was an early
advocate of action on the climate well
some of her supporters have claimed this
that that it's that climate change uh
warning was uh
a forgotten legacy she made a big speech
at the united nations
in 1989 warning about climate change and
global warming in actual fact it was
because the green
party uh had polled 15 percent of the
votes in the european elections in
uh 1989 really shocked the tory party
now what the prime minister has said in
a briefing
to uh journalists up in scotland
off-camera print journalists
he said on the whole issue of wind power
and getting away from fossil fuels
look at what we've done already we've
transitioned away from coal
in my lifetime thanks to margaret
thatcher
who closed so many coal mines across the
country we had a big
early start and now we're now moving
rapidly away from coal altogether now
it is claimed by those present that when
he mentioned margaret thatcher closing
the coal mines
he laughed and then said to the
journalists i thought that would get you
going
anyway that the laughter uh and uh has
outraged many politicians as much as the
remark itself
sir kia starmer has said on twitter
boris johnson's
shameful praising of margaret thatcher's
closure of the coal mines
brushing off the devastating impact on
those communities
with a laugh shows just how out of touch
he is
with working people nicholas sturgeon
has accused him of being crass
and insensitive now most people looking
back at the 80s
would say hold on a minute it wasn't
about the environment it was about
crushing the miners about uneconomic
pits do you remember she used that
phrase the enemy within
um it was all about a battle with the
unions
the environment wasn't mentioned at the
time at all um so boris johnson i think
he's
got this wrong and he probably realized
his claim is a bit ridiculous fact he
laughed
and perhaps made things worse anyway
predictable row
from the political opponents the tories
will worry a bit more though
about the impact of these remarks in
those red wall constituencies
many of whom many of which were former
mining communities
where the tories won seats the last
election i wouldn't thought they'd
appreciate these comments